- Je dis toujours que ce qui l'a
tuée c'est la stigmatisation.
Elle s'est isolée pour consommer
seule.
- Sa fille, Sara-Jeanne, est
morte seule d'une surdose,
en 2019. Isabelle Fortier est
convaincue que si davantage
de ressources avai
sa disposition, les choses
auraient pu être différentes.
ISABELLE FORTIER, représentante
du Québec, Mom stops the harm
- On ne prend pas en
considération l'importance dee
cette crise-là, puis les impacts
que ça a sur des milliers
de familles canadiennes.
- La santé publique de Montréal
propose de décriminaliser la
possession simple de drogue dure
comme le fera la Colombie-
Britannique dès l'an prochain.
Dr eYLE
gQHqáZ]
santé publique de Montréal
- Puis, on a tout avantage
à aller dans ce sens-là
parce qu'on le voit, la
judiciarisation pour les
consommateurs a des effets
importants pour eux en terme
d'accès aux services,
de stigmatisation.
- Un outil à ajouter à l'arsenal
de luttes selon la Docteur
Mylène Drouin pour éviter que
la situation des surdose ne
s'aggrave à Montréal.
- On le voit, on a plus
de surdose.
- La crise n'est pas moins
importante ici, toute proportion
gardée.
- Des organismes de prévention
comme Cactus Montréal constatent
aussi l'urgence d'agir, mais
déplorent l'inaction du
gouvernement provincial.
LOUIS LETELLIER DE JUST,
président Cactus Montréal
- Ça ne veut pas dire qu'on a
nécessairement besoin d'eux
à chas étapes.
- En 2021, le conseil municipal
de Montréal a demandé à Ottawa
d'aller de l'avant avec
la décriminalisation de
possession simple de drogue.
Toronto a fait de même.
Le gouvernement fédéral n'a pas
d'échéancier pour le moment.
DAVID LAMETTI, ministre de
la justice
- On est ouverts à parler
aux autres maires, mairesses
et premiers ministres
des provinces.
- C'est frustrant pour nous.
C'est vraiment frustrant de...
d'avoir à se battre et de se
dire : On a des solutions
faciles à ce problème-là, mais
le gouvernement nous dit : "On
peut pas faire ça, on peut pasas
faire ça."
- Comme bien des proches
éprouvés, Isabelle Fortier est
d'avis qu'il faut agir
maintenant. Attendre la fin
du projet pilote de la Colombie-
Britannique nous mènerait à2026,
selon elle.
Ici Kim Vermette,
Radio-Canada, Mon